We're going to continue solving equations and this time, we're going to solve
some radical equations. We'll use our knowledge of radicals and powers to help
us out. When we solve radical equations like this one, we want to isolate the
square root or the root on one side of the equals sign. This equation already
has the radical on one side of the equals sign. This radical is actually a
grouping symbol, and the quantity p plus 1 is underneath of it. So, when we're
trying to find the value of p, we want to undo the square root. To undo the
square root, you want to square both sides of our equation. We know this since
a square power undoes the square root. So, try finishing this problem. What
would you get for p?